getting through security at mccarran
airport will now be easier with the
latest upgrades in aviation security
technologies
madison kimbrough joins us live on what
you can expect when headed through tsa
checkpoints hi madison
yes hello this is very exciting as this
is the official opening of mccarran's
innovation checkpoint
and take a look how cool is it that we
get to bring this to you live right in
front of it
as this is going to offer a lot of new
features for travelers
now it's described as the first and only
one of its kind
in the nation this checkpoint offers
additional security screenings
for extra protection but it shouldn't
add to a person's wait time
new digital signs allow for travelers to
easily see what they can
and can't bring through security and
also show security wait
times one of the biggest features
credential authentication technology
that's also known as cat federal tsa
security director for nevada karen burke
says
this system takes away the need for a
boarding pass and all you need is an id
i would tell you the crown jewel of test
sites for tsa
and for the future of aviation security
is right behind me
this is absolutely the most superb and
one of a kind
the only one in the country that has
this kind of technology
and the ability to do testing to be able
to have
a great customer experience as well as a
good
environment for our employees as well
other features include an automated bin
return with a mechanism that uses an
ultraviolet light system to clean bins
plexiglas barriers and new body scanners
which will reduce the number of pat
downs and what you're going to see right
here is this
is the barriers that we were talking
about as far as
the where you don't have to touch and
it's the bins so it
has this automatic system it's so
amazing and you can see it turns green
right over here so pretty cool this
grand opening starts
on thursday morning so look out for that
reporting live from inside of mccarran
airport
madison kimbrough 8 news now